[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
Ben has left the show we should get
that's the big news oh that was a big
news that's the big news best no longer
with the show it wasn't over money he
was offered a lot of money to stay but
he wants to do other creative things see
you know I receive stay tuned for the
next Ben Avery project whatever it is
[Music]
somehow it's already been two months
since Ben Avery left the Tim Dillon show
October 5th is when he officially
announced on Instagram that he's no
longer Tim's producer but has been
working on some projects on the side and
is excited to share them with all of us
as soon as he possibly can well
apparently one of these projects was
lemon party a brand new podcast
featuring Ben Avery Devin Costa and
Ben's brother Jace may I offer you some
advice yeah start smoking cigarettes are
we on Devin let's go we're rolling yeah
Devin I want you to go out right now go
get uh Jason carton a carton of
cigarettes I need him to start trying to
distracts that we need this podcast to
be funny damn it I can't have him being
sad I mean do you know how much more
money we'd be making if we all started
if you guys started drinking with me
yeah we just went raw I'm willing to do
that as a patreon goal I will relapse on
the show live on the show
if we get to a certain number you'll
throw it how much well I already put the
page which Jay thought was very funny I
put the patreon goal at a hundred
thousand dollars a month yeah Tesla
we'll get the cyber truck and put the
decal of the lemon party guys on the
side and turn the inside of the Cyber
truck into a podcast Studio on top of
this my promise to you the The Listener
at home I will also be insanely hammered
I will relapse and I will drunk Drive
the Cyber truck across L.A while
podcasting across all of La campaign and
guys this will be our O.J Simpson uh
moment where we're like the helicopters
are following us or three white guys are
podcasting they're going down yeah we're
going down be the O.J Simpson case but
everyone is no one is rooting for us
people are on the 405 holding up signs
it says kill yourself then pull over
stopped you stop stop
so the show's called lemon party it
comes out once a week on YouTube with
additional episodes posted to patreon
now normally it can be hard to just jump
into a brand new random podcast right
off the bat but listening to Ben for so
many years on the Tim Dillon show
sitting alongside Tim his laugh his
voice all that stuff it gives this new
podcast a comfortable feel right away by
the way I will say if uh
people that do become pedophile
Vigilantes okay not the worst gig like
uh doesn't pay that well and the cops
will ask you to stop but it's not
against the law but they probably like
they like yeah they don't they treat you
kind of okay because they're like it's
[ __ ] no the cops hate it because
you're making them look bad so like
would you knock it off just let them do
what they're gonna do well and we'll do
nothing or don't you know how this works
but come on you've seen us how we
handled Uvaldi we know what we're doing
here [ __ ] off
we stand outside while the kids get
raped I was playing Candy Crush
and people like the kids are getting
raped stop and we're like it's dead we
could get raped
another thing that this podcast doesn't
have that brand new podcasts usually do
is very awkward early on episodes you
know the first few episodes of a brand
new show can usually be kind of strange
while they're still trying to figure out
what the show is going to be this show
has none of that the guys seem very
Savvy on screen right off the bat and
have a great dynamic between the three
of them I mean two of them are literally
brothers so I guess that makes sense but
nonetheless it's a great Vibe I'm fully
expecting Boston Dynamics to tweet a
video they've taught a robot to like
fire a gun or something or like use a
sword well I guess robots will be the
cops one day I saw this uh movie have
you ever heard of it it's called RoboCop
folks have you seen this
I I turned on the TV the other day this
movie I go is that robot a cop and then
uh in credits roll turns out the movie's
called robocon
short for robotic cop
I have a stroke
we just finished the pod
by the way speaking of people that say
have you seen this have you heard about
this Jay Leno is horribly disfigured now
that's right which has kind of been
making me laugh a lot and I feel bad but
it is very funny to think about it he's
uh he's
they're just patching denim to his face
he's like just make just make the whole
damn thing denim he's like make me a
Blue Jean Baby turn me into an old fire
truck
I am waiting like one day to just be
walking down Melrose and he's just like
driving a house yeah I guess everything
he owns is on wheels
but a kid coming over from school I saw
him on the five freeway with my mom he
was driving a fire truck
like it was a boat and we like honked
and he waved and [ __ ] and then he
crashed and burned he lives before
making this video I watched all the
episodes that they've uploaded to
YouTube so far and I think this is a
funny podcast it's very good so far it
is still kind of weird to hear Ben
Avery's very distinct laughter look at
the screen and not see Tim Dylan but the
support seems to be there it has 7 000
subscribers on their page and it's only
been about three weeks since they upload
their first episode I'd expect there to
be a lot of support behind this show
just based on the fact that so many
people were angry with Tim the way that
he treated Ben during the end there just
the fact that people are upset that Ben
Avery is not the producer of the Tim
Dylan show anymore seems like Ben had a
lot of momentum behind him so I'd expect
this show to keep getting support from
the comedy community the fourth
amendment is to have the biggest red as
face in America
and the Fifth Amendment is to weigh 400
pounds but have a size 28 waist somehow
because you're just shaped like a
[ __ ] water balloon
punish her t-shirt and like those types
of punish her t-shirt who's legitimately
shaped like a [ __ ] cartoon of a
chicken yeah yeah he's wearing a
tablecloth from Walmart
and he goes she's like sorry I just love
this this country and then his his nose
explodes because he's been he's been
drinking [ __ ] whiskey since 8 A.M
sorry I respect a little bit of hard
work that's why I go down to the job
site and yell at Mexicans all day his
nose has developed like an aorta it's
got all these like it's like a heart
has Dick veins in it he's tying two
belts together to put around his waist
yeah he's got an extender for his belt
oh like on airlines you're too fat for
the southwest and they have to hand you
the really long seatbelt extender yeah
you have to go excuse me I've ruined my
wife
and they go oh right away sir
he's cute
he's
cute
um yes excuse me I've thrown everything
away
for egg rolls from Panda Express which
are so good which are so they are so
good Panda Express is so good it's
almost worth it I love Panda Express I
think this podcast is going to be around
for a little bit it's well produced they
have a great dynamic between the three
guys they riff really well it's
everything that you want in a modern day
comedy podcast so if you'd like to check
out lemon party you can head over to Ben
Avery's YouTube channel and find the
first four episodes for free there they
also have additional episodes on their
patreon like I mentioned thank you so
much for watching this video this video
right here on joke world please
subscribe for all your comedy needs if
you want to stay in the comedy Loop hear
about new podcasts like this hear about
old podcasts too any sort of podcast
subscribe to joke world right now it
would mean a lot to me doesn't do much
for you besides staying in the comedy
Loop and getting all your favorite
comedy news you know all in one place
and really making your life easier to be
a comedy fan but it does a lot for me
subscribe
[Music]